this episode is made possible by the
realistic online game war thunder check
out this game through the link in the
description below go through that link
and not only do you support this show
that you also get a free premium tank or
an aircraft and three days of premium
time as a bonus let's get into it from
humble beginnings in rural Kansas Dwight
David Eisenhower rose to become the most
powerful man on the planet before
reaching that pinnacle he took charge of
the Allied defenses against the Nazi
beast that was roaring across Europe he
led the world to victory becoming the
undisputed man of the hour before
leading America through the fabulous 50s
in today's bhaiyya graphics we learn
about the 34th President of the United
States Dwight Eisenhower Dwight David
Eisenhower was born on the 14th of
October 1890 in Denison Texas his
parents had lived in Abilene Kansas
before his birth and it was there that
they returned when he was just an infant
as a child he was involved in an
accident that cost his younger brother
and I he later referred to this as an
experience that taught him the need to
be protective of those who are under him
his childhood there it was active eager
and happy sports played an important
part in his development and he excelled
in baseball both in school and on a
vacant lot next to his home Eisenhower
said that not making the baseball team
at West Point was one of the greatest
disappointments of my life
maybe my greatest yet football it was
his first love he made the varsity
football team and was a starter as
running back and linebacker in 1912 when
he tackled the legendary Jim Thorpe of
the Carlisle Indians though sport was
important the greatest staple of the
Eisenhower family was religious
observance the Bible was the guide to
family life while speaking of himself in
1948 Eisenhower said he was one of the
most deeply religious men I know though
unattached to any sect or organization
the Eisenhower home was also a home of
patriotism as well as faith and one of
respect for things of the mind
competition and hard work were staples
of the family routine young Eisenhower
worked during his spare time at a
Creamery while he was at school
[Music]
Dwight was 20 when he left
Abilene his destination was the Military
Academy at West Point he graduated in
1915 and was commissioned as a second
lieutenant of infantry he graduated in
the middle of his class which came to be
known as the class that the stars fell
on because 59 members eventually became
general officers in the summer of 1916
as a newly promoted first lieutenant
stationed at Fort Sam Houston Texas
Dwight married
mammy Geneva Dowd of Denver she was his
wife until Eisenhower's death in 1969
events in Europe they were forging a new
way of life for the entire world
World War one gave many officers their
first experience of combat but young
Eisenhower was not among them it brought
him instead command of a training center
at Gettysburg Pennsylvania there he
prepared troops of a new tank corps for
overseas deployment his performance won
him the Distinguished Service Medal he
was stationed to Europe but before he
could get there the war had ended
[Music]
in the late 1920s after graduation from
the command school and General Staff
school major Dwight D Eisenhower was
assigned to France to prepare a
guidebook on American battlefields in
Europe it was his first direct
experience with that continent in the
1930s he served under many talented
generals such as John J Pershing and
General Douglas MacArthur in the
Philippines he worked for MacArthur for
four years he was commander-in-chief of
the Philippine Army and he was helping
the Commonwealth government work out
plan for its military defense Eisenhower
had strong philosophical disagreements
with MacArthur regarding the leadership
qualities that an American army officer
should develop in his subordinates the
resulting animosity between Eisenhower
and MacArthur it lasted for the rest of
their lives ordered back to the United
States in December of 1939 Eisenhower
went to Fort Lewis Washington as an
executive officer of the 15th Infantry
Regiment in the dark spring of 1940
German armored divisions were crashing
through Holland and Belgium the
Luftwaffe
it was streaking its destruction through
European skies France was being
subjugated and Britain was left standing
alone the United States had passed the
Selective Service Act to prepare for
what inevitably lay ahead late in 1940
Eisenhower was made chief of staff of
the 3rd Infantry Division his staff work
brought with it an assignment as chief
of staff of the 9th Army Corps in the
summer of 1941 he became the chief of
staff to Colonel Walter Kreuger whose
newly organized Third Army was preparing
to participate in the most realistic war
maneuvers ever held by American troops
in these maneuvers over the Louisiana
countryside Eisenhower's task was to
work out a plan of defense against an
invading mass force soon the maneuvers
were over and Eisenhower was promoted to
Brigadier General then within a matter
of days came the bombing of Pearl Harbor
although his supervisory abilities had
been noticed before entry into World War
two he had never held an active command
above a battalion and was far from being
considered as a commander of major
operations
[Music]
from almost this moment on the fate of
the nation and the fate of general D
Eisenhower would be inexorably bound
together called to Washington in the
first weeks after the war began
Eisenhower went to work in the war plans
office of the War Department one of the
plans formulated during this time was
the central strategic determination to
make an eventual attack across the
English Channel this was to be called
the principal allied defensive effort
Eisenhower's ability to rise to grieve
responsibility brought him rapid
promotion because an all-out channel
invasion would be impossible before 1944
and because the need for offensive
action was immediate in 1942 the Allies
undertook a combined operation under the
command of General Dwight Eisenhower and
that was the invasion of North Africa
the minimum objective of this maneuver
was to seize the ports between
Casablanca and Algiers along the rim of
the North African coast troops were put
ashore in late November encountering
resistance ranging from miles in Algiers
to surprisingly stiff at Casablanca the
commander's hope was to push quickly
along the east of the Mediterranean and
take possession of the important posts
of bézier and Tunis but a number of
unfavorable circumstances including
treacherous weather conditions prompted
the commander to hold off on his vital
assault in the spring however troops of
Omar Bradley's 2nd Corps were able to
take bézier and at the same time Tunis
fell to the British 1st Army with these
victories well that was the end of the
axis Empire in Africa the Allied leaders
and the men who had fought under them
proudly commemorated their victory one
of the greatest products of the victory
in the words of onerror himself was the
progress achieved in the welding of
Allied unity and the establishment of a
combat team that was already showing the
effects of a growing confidence amongst
all its members the end of this campaign
it brought personal recognition to
Eisenhower throughout the world as him
being a great leader the commander
himself interpreted this recognition is
proof that free men can find unity in
victory even against seemingly
invincible odds
[Music]
the next big campaign the invasion of
Sicily brought further demonstration of
this basic truth allied troops took this
vital rock in the summer of 1943 the
effects of Sicily's fall they were
electric Italy surrendered the first of
the Axis powers do capitulate now the
Allies prepared for what was to be the
most fiercely fought battle of the
Mediterranean war the invasion of Italy
itself at solana through a miracle of
courage and tenacity Lieutenant General
Mark Clark army established a beachhead
overwhelming German odds and taking
Solano and the vital port of Naples with
these victories although heavy fighting
and important battles did lay ahead
the first major objectives of the Italy
campaign were accomplished Allied forces
were on European soil and they were able
to pin down German troops far from the
scene of the cross-channel invasion
which was planned for the following year
President Roosevelt visited the combat
area with General Eisenhower when he
came over for the Cairo and Tehran
conferences their agreement was once
again established that the principal
Allied effort would be the invasion of
Europe shortly afterwards the man who
would oversee this awesome undertaking
was named and yes of course it was to be
General Dwight David Eisenhower people
throughout the free world were now
calling him the man of the hour
the supreme commanders orders from the
General Staff they were quite simple
land on the coast of France and
thereafter destroy the German ground
forces yet between the order and its
execution well there was certainly going
to be a lot of effort across the channel
the heavy fortifications lining the
coast of France bespoke the Nazis belief
that they could simply push back any
invading army in France alone
fifty-eight German divisions were
waiting preparing for this invasion was
a job without let-up incessant and
realistic training it was of paramount
importance the challenges of morale the
myriad details of coordination on every
level all of these were simply
overwhelming but through these tense
months in the early part of 1944 the
operations they continued finally after
being postponed for one day because of
weather conditions the eve of the day of
decision was at hand the commands
visited the airborne troops who would
lead the invasion he later wrote I found
the men in fine fettle joshing and
assuring me that I had no cause for
worry yes with the fate of the war
hanging in the balance
Eisenhower felt the weight of the world
on his shoulders so if you're on all of
the fun of battle without you know for
death and the horror and the abject
awfulness well you should probably check
out today's sponsor war thunder
[Music]
war thunder is a realistic free-to-play
military vehicle combat game war thunder
is available on PC ps4 and Xbox one and
I realize in recording this ad that I
don't know if it's a good thing but I
have all of those platforms but the good
news is you only need one of them no
need to purchase you could just download
and get playing
it's game there are over 1200
historically accurate vehicles all the
way from the 1920s to the 1990s they're
all carefully built and incredibly
detailed and all of the physics as well
it's been sweated over so it's just very
very good bus sound is good the music
the sound effects it's all it's it's
just really excellent and look you can
just jump in play a quick arcade game
useful if you don't have much time or
you could play a more realistic version
a challenging tactical situation or if
you're hardcore
you can try simulator and that's one
I've never done because I don't like
having my arse whips over and over again
so join us on the battlefield for free
using the link below doing that also
supports this show and it gets you a
free premium tank or aircraft and three
days of premium time as a bonus just for
registering let's get into the rest of
the video
[Music]
moving the largest invasion force in the
history of mankind across the English
Channel was a huge logistical challenge
but the success of the enterprise it was
largely dependent on something outside
of Eisenhower's control and that was the
weather with the arrival of June there
were just four days of potential good
weather that Eisenhower could work with
the invasion it was planned for June the
fifth but then bad weather rolled in on
the fourth with the expectation of more
to come
Eisenhower therefore considered
postponing the invasion on the other
side of the channel the Germans they
were confident that there would be no
invasion attempt during the inclement
weather and it was at this point that
the supreme Allied commander had a
decision to make and finally he told his
generals I don't like it but we have to
go on June the 5th at 9:45 p.m. he gave
the order for the landings to begin the
following morning on June the 6th he
said ok let's go he then addressed the
airman the sailors the troops of his
command stating you are about to embark
on the Great Crusade the eyes of the
world are upon you in company with our
brave allies and brothers-in-arms on
other fronts you will bring about the
destruction of the German war machine
and the elimination of Nazi tyranny your
task will not be an easy one your enemy
as well-trained and well-equipped and
battle-hardened we will accept nothing
less than full victory good luck and let
us beseech the blessing of Almighty God
upon this great and noble undertaking in
the Wallis of the supreme commander
Allied expeditionary force however was
secret at the following note dated June
the 5th our landings in the Shabak half
area have failed to gain a satisfactory
foothold and I've withdrawn the troops
my decision to attack at this time and
place was based upon the best
information available the troops the
Aran Navy did all that the bravery and
devotion to duty could do if any blame
or fault attaches to the attempt it is
mine alone those last two words mine
alone they were underlined by Eisenhower
at 3 a.m. on June the 6th President
Roosevelt was telephoned with the
information that Operation Overlord was
under way just two days later Eisenhower
was able to report to his president that
the operation was a success throughout
d-day June the 6th a hundred of 56
thousand one hundred and fifteen men
nine
on the beaches of Normandy by the end of
June in excess of 850,000 men along with
570 thousand tons of supplies in 148
thousand vehicles they were on French
soil the unstoppable march to Berlin was
underway the nasty surrender came on May
the 7th 1945 the Japanese followed just
four months later but only after the
u.s. dropped two atomic bombs on their
people Eisenhower was opposed to the
dropping of the bombs after they were
unleashed he said first the Japanese
were ready to surrender and it wasn't
necessary to hit them with that awful
thing second I hated to see our country
be the first to use such a weapon for
Dwight Eisenhower the return from war
was met with the cheers of people from
all over the world in his own homeland a
hero's welcome awaited him despite his
desire to enter retirement America they
had other tasks waiting for their
favorite soldier he succeeded general
Marshall as the Army's first post-war
chief of staff he expressed belief that
one of the greatest pillars of World
Peace was a strong United States and
visited troops stationed in various
parts of the world and encouraged
America's growing sense of global
responsibility saying we must remain the
first champions of those who seek peace
in their own lives and peace with their
neighbors finally on February the 7th
1948 the general from Abilene after 36
years of service to his country left
active military assignments he did not
however leave active participation in
the life of his nation he accepted an
invitation from Columbia University to
serve as president of that institution
at the time he thought that this would
enable him to devote the remainder of
his time on earth to the challenges of
education but events of the post-war
world they dictated otherwise the urgent
need for unity in the free world brought
into being the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization or NATO it soon became
clear that there was only one man who
could make that vital and complicated
organization work and that was
Eisenhower at the end of 1950 he
answered his country's call once more
and he again was on European soil to
take supreme commands of the land the
sea and the air forces of a grand
defensive alliance against the new
threat arising from the Soviets who had
previously been his nations
a lie he had to create within the
war-weary european soul the will to
defend itself so that freedom so dearly
bought would not be lost for more than a
year he labored diligently at his task
of coalition when he turned over the
reins of command to general Matthew
Ridgway the structure of military unity
among the free nations upon which rested
the hope for continued peace it was well
established
once again with the establishments of
substantial victory behinds in this
might well have been the ends of
Eisenhower's public career indeed this
was the end of Eisenhower the soldier
but it was just the beginning of
Eisenhower The Statesman although he had
shown no interest in politics Eisenhower
was pursued as a presidential candidate
by both the Republicans and the
Democrats dissatisfied with the
Democrats over their handling of the
Korean War and charges of corruption
within the White House Eisenhower
decided and joined the Republicans and
run for office he felt that the country
needed him as he watched the country
going in the wrong direction he knew
that he was the right man to get things
back on track beyond his military
reputation Eisenhower was a very
charismatic individual I like Ike was
more than just a campaign slogan it was
a true sentiment he was seen as a decent
man who was willing to put himself
forward to do what was right for the
country when what he truly deserved was
to live out his final years in peace and
seclusion his overwhelming popularity
had catapulted him to the White House
and while most people liked and trusted
Ike they weren't always sure that he was
engaged in Oval Office affairs a lot of
people felt that it was simply presiding
over an administration and that others
were really making the decisions however
although he had a reputation for being
out to lunch every major policy decision
really was his decision it was really
him who was calling the shots in his
first significant accomplishments
Eisenhower brought about an end to the
Korean War forging an armistice that is
still in effect today while his military
career has been built on waging war now
it appeared that he was determined to
use his presidency to pursue peace he
began downsizing the military by
spending less money on defense he
believed that America could spend more
on infrastructure and quality of life he
went from orchestrating the largest
military operation in history to pushing
the world's largest public works project
through Congress the Federal Highway Act
while Americans welcomes the change to
their landscape they were not receptive
to other changes to their culture one of
the great unresolved issues after World
War 2 was whether or not African
Americans would continue to be forced to
live in a segregated society in 1954 the
Supreme Court bans racial segregation in
public schools in its landmark ruling of
Brown versus Board of Education
although Eisenhower had
Chief Justice Earl Warren the motivating
force behind the Revolutionary ruling
eisenhower publicly distanced himself
from the decision considering it to be a
disruptive and inappropriate role for
the federal government in his eyes the
country it was not yet ready for
desegregation words that he shared with
Warren in private they confirm this
Eisenhower asked him to consider the
perspective of white parents in the deep
south these are not bad people
the president said all they are
concerned about is to see that their
sweet little girls are not required to
sit in school alongside some big black
bucks in 1954 after the French were
defeated in Vietnam in the country was
split in two
Eisenhower pledged his support for the
pro-western government of South Vietnam
over the Communists run north he took a
series of steps there were essential to
America's growing involvement in Vietnam
the most important was the creation of
the Bank of Vietnam through which huge
sums of money were sent to South Vietnam
for aid and support under Ike's
leadership America enjoyed peace and
great prosperity during his first term
with the economy soaring he easily won
re-election in 1956 an interesting note
here is that during his presidency
Eisenhower was on the maiden flight of
Air Force one which replaced the
previous presidential aircraft the
columbine traditionally second
presidential terms of much tougher than
the first and this was certainly true
for Eisenhower first he had health
concerns suffering a heart attack in
1955 that combined with his aloof
reactions do growing civil rights unrest
made him seem rather weak then came
Sputnik the first satellite in space
launched by the Soviets in 1957
Americans they became hysterical
believing that there was a missile gap
in the Russians favor in 1959 Fidel
Castro seized power in Cuba establishing
a revolutionary regime just 90 miles
from Florida that was another sign that
America was losing out the Soviets there
was now a feeling that communism was
overwhelming America the grandfatherly
imaged that Eisenhower had enjoyed was
now seen as a bit of a liability in his
final address to the nation he spoke to
the American people with unprecedented
candor he warns that Americans must
guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted influence by the
military-industrial complex for a
military man yet alone the general who
had been the supreme commander of the
Allied forces this
was a stunning pronouncement the hero of
World War two he wanted nothing more
than to leave behind a presidential
legacy of peace to him a man who had
fought and seen firsthand the
destruction of war combat it always had
to be the very last resort
[Music]
in accordance with the 22nd amendment to
the US Constitution Eisenhower was the
first president to be affected by the
prohibition on running for a third term
following the end of his second term in
January of 1961 his commission as a
five-star general was reinstated and he
took up residence at a working farm
opposite the Gettysburg battlefield in
Pennsylvania
throughout the 1960s Eisenhower gave his
influential support to a number of
Republican politicians including Barry
Goldwater and Richard Nixon when Nixon
won the presidency in 1968 Eisenhower
commented that it was a day for
rejoicing eisenhower died on March the
28th 1969 of congestive heart failure he
was 78 years of age he was eulogized by
President Nixon with the following words
some men are considered great because
they lead great armies or they lead
powerful nations for eight years now
Dwight Eisenhower has neither commanded
an army nor led a nation and yet he
remained through his final days the
world's most admired and respected man
truly the first citizen of the world so
I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do give us
a thumbs up below and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
just like this several times a week so
subscribe you'll find out about all of
those also feeling was something else to
watch why not check out my other channel
called today I found out you'll find a
link to that below and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]